don't press my name is sorry I feel a
little sick I don't know what happened
edgert bit me a couple days ago and ever
since my skin's been falling off and I
have this incredible urge to play the
walking dead road to survival so that's
what we're gonna do today
oh the look there's look Rick I really
really would like to chew up his nipples
oh they're fighting together oh look
there's me and my friends now Rick why
are you shooting me Hershel goddamn it
her she's got an adrenaline rush it's
killing all my friends god damn it okay
so I'll pick whatever will do worse for
him because I'm actually on the other
side of this game put it down and watch
your banks this human trait is strong
damn it
Rick is alert damn it attack the strong
character for best and arcane I don't
care about these guys they can die for
all I care The Walking Dead wrote to
survival 10 months earlier okay cool
fighter puts oh I get to build my own
house nice
I'll build a material first build a
beautiful house have a nice little
garden grow a couple of my friends oh
look there was my friends what are they
doing I can see my reflection in the
iPad and his system I bet if there was a
real outbreak Walker's I'd probably be
going pretty quick I'd probably let one
of them bite me anyway and just just go
with it I mean I obviously look really
attractive they have guns I have a knife
and a freaking baseball bat but we're
kicking their asses oh yeah
you have saved some survivors from what
wave of Walker's damn it that was my
breakfast goddamn it [ __ ] walkies the
gunfire you mean
alright there's my friends get up I
don't know they're killing them
oh she's pretty much yeah no let's see
huh yeah baby
whoa David it's over
it's all over I'm sick of living like
this yes this is perfect do it David
take it easy
we're just getting started here okay so
now have the option that's crazy there's
a place for everyone
don't do it Petey pie tell him we need
him right oh hell no tell him to kill
him that's horrible
I mean that's great this is this is
gonna be great lunch for me he shoots
himself
that's hardcore man that's Doric Oh God
yes this is our moment
get him get him these other people
chatting do the same thing as I did it
goes against my principles to kill them
but I have to progress for you break we
got the people at the gate who are you
names tarik oh yeah there's Rick this is
Mitch Michonne
that's Glen oh my god Glenn Oh Michonne
yeah that's cool
got all the characters can't wait to eat
him
someone wrote to me yes meat bag it's
the way you look what how dare you this
is a really cool game I live a link to
it to check out in the description
Walking Dead rose to survival I Garrett
how dare you do you recognize me do you
like me like this again what a kiss
coach please no come on all right
friends hope you enjoyed this episode if
you did punch that like button and I
won't bite you leave a comment how
beautiful I am and I'll see you in the
next one as always stay awesome okay
[ __ ] you twice is so creepy
princess X Allah